it's a historic moment for inflation
because it's got up to the highest level
that we've seen since the 1980s have a
look at that 11.1 percent higher than
economists had expected higher since
1981 and consider the history here look
back in the 1970s there was this period
of stagflation so stagnant economy high
in flesh and toxic combination then we
had the period over the last few decades
low inflation and the concern is are we
heading back now to that kind of an era
all over again we don't know in the UK
but that is the big question here and
elsewhere too now there is a big
Divergence in experience of inflation
look this is breaking it down from
lowest to highest income groups and
probably you can see the pattern higher
inflation for low-income groups lower
inflation for high income groups so
there's a distributional question here
about rich and poor when it comes to
inflation and there's also a big
question about where inflation is
highest in terms of the different items
have a look at this this is showing you
different sectors clothing up by nine
percent food and veg up by 15 16 that's
meats and fish as well Hotel inflation
so it's not just food it's not just
Goods up by 18 having real trouble
getting workers they're eggs and butter
you can see it's mounting 22 30
margarine if you don't want butter I'm
afraid that's up even more 42 percent
milk
up by 48 but have a look at this Above
All Else obviously gas prices this was
the month that gas prices kicked in and
actually it's broken our access there
it's gone up to 128 but it's not all one
way look cars second-hand cars they were
Rising very fast not long ago weren't
they now down by three percent year on
year so that's the big story for
inflation of course there's something
else going on which is the Autumn
statement and we're going to hear more
from the chancellor about whether he's
going to be putting stimulus into the
economy or contraction and you know we
all know which way it's heading
basically that of course was the
pandemic look the furlough scheme lots
of money going up then money coming back
in but have a look what's expected in
the next few years year after year of
contraction pulling money back out of
the economy austerity whatever you want
to call it spending cuts tax Rises and a
lot of people would ask whether that's
the right thing to be doing given the
economy as a recession given You've Got
High interest rates and of course
inflation at near record levels